alors qu'il assistait à une conférence
dans le cadre des assises du journalisme
à tour l'ancien ministre de l'écologie
nicolas hulot a dû quitter l'assistance
en raison d'un mouvement féministe à son
encontre
[Applaudissements]
la raison le 11 juillet 2008 une femme a
porté plainte pour viol contre les
militants écologistes une plainte qui
accusait l'homme d'avoir eu recours à
une relation sexuelle sous la contrainte
onze ans plus tôt en 1997 pourtant si
nicolas hulot avait tout de suite été
entendue dès 2008 la plainte avait
finalement été classée sans suite à
cette époque là ça n'avait parlé de
cette affaire dans la presse il aura
fallu attendre 2018 et que l'homme soit
ministre de l'écologie pour que la faire
éclater au grand jour sans que les
médias n'en parlent vraiment plainte
pour dénoncer un fait de viol lors de
cette conférence mouvementée mercredi
dernier l'ancien ministre a tout de
suite tenu à s'adresser aux féministes
en colère avant de quitter la salle je
vous remercie de vous transformer devant
cette salle en procureur la justice a
parlé un happening qui met en lumière le
manque de médiatisation autour de cette
affaire de viol présumé alors accusé de
viol comprenez vous que nicolas hulot
était pris à partie
merci à jean michel aphatie d'être avec
nous on semble oublier les amateurs les
coulisses d'un quinquennat burn out des
missions crise on panique le voile se
déchire sur le quinquennat vous allez
nous parler à nous raconter ça dans un
instant et vous évoquez bien sûr l
affaire nicolas hulot c'est une affaire
de fous je vous le dis merci de venir
nous éclairer ce soir hier il s'est
passé voilà qu'un groupe a interrompu
l'ancien ministre de l'écologie avec des
camps parts des pancartes mentionnant
ces accusations de viol ça fait
énormément parler regarde alors ce que
je vais faire c'est que comme je vois
qu'il ya des gens c'était prévu ne vous
inquiétez pas vous étés mesdames
je suis désolé je vais très vite essayer
de faire en sorte qu'on revienne au
sujet du jour vous avez des personnes
ici voilà qui viennent
porter je ne sais pas si c'est des
intimidations ou des accusations alors
immédiatement nicolas hulot a tenu à
réagir et à répondre en expliquant que
la justice était passé regarde vous
venez d re turbé cette manifestation
pour faire référence à une affaire pour
laquelle j'ai été entendu il ya 25 ans
par un procureur
dont je vais faire ce que vous auriez dû
faire
ils sentent le sentiment de honte ne
vous était pas épargné simplement vous
lire ce que le procureur de l'époque
a bien voulu dire on les faits dénoncés
en tout état de cause
n'apparaissent en aucun cas établi ça a
été jugé par la justice je vous remercie
de vous transformer devant cette salle
en procureur la justice a parlé
ça alors il entend ensuite de nouveau
été interrompu avant de décider de
partir regarde je suis désolée de ce
spectacle
[Musique]
je vais présenter mes excuses à la salle
je suis un être humain je suis pas dans
la disposition d'esprit ce soir
d'aborder ce sujet qui est le sujet le
plus important du siècle mais je ne
resterai pas dans cette soirée parce que
le climat s'y prête pas or ce qui me
concerne j'avais effectivement beaucoup
de choses à dire mais je serai que vos
expériences et vos regards combleront
largement mon départ mille pardons
a donc ça c'était hier ça fait
énormément parler déjà avant qu'on ait
les explications de jean michel est ce
que vous comprenez ce genre voilà
d'intervention ici autour de la table
valérie est là ce qui était pointé du
doigt c'était le fait qu'il participait
à une table ronde qui parlait de la
responsabilité de la presse là en
l'occurrence sur le sur le climat et que
par ailleurs on estimait que la presse
avait mis un couvercle cette affaire
donc c'était ce paradoxe lac était
pointée du doigt par ces femmes là donc
c'est pour ça qu'elles sont intervenues
et qu'elles sont venues dire qu'il
n'avait pas sa place sur cette table
ronde là précisément alors jean michel
aphatie est avec nous dans un livre paru
le 8 septembre le journaliste politique
revient sur la plainte pour viol contre
nicolas hulot déposé en 2008 pour lui la
lumière n'a pas été complètement faite
sur cette affaire c'est dans la nuit et
voilà il dit tout dans ce livre et
notamment s'étant 97 que les faits
auraient eu lieu selon l'accusatrice
pascal mitterrand la petite fille de
l'ancien président de la république
qu'est ce qui s'est passé selon pascal
mitterrand michel
sait on entre dans le
le récit par l'
élite photographe stagiaire chez sipa
viennent de terminer elle a passé un bac
professionnel dans les pyrénées
atlantiques pour faire du photoreportage
et le patron de sipa boxing sipahioglu
lui dit nicolas hulot vient d'acheter
une villa en corse il confie
l'exclusivité du reportage d'une énorme
vedette à cette époque sur les genoux
rappelle pris l'exclusivité du reportage
ainsi pas il a travaillé à vendre ainsi
pas qu'on est très bien sipahioglu y
connais très bien ce monde là nicolas
hulot et il veut que ce soit toi t il
faire le reportage et elle répond ainsi
pas alors cette partie du récit c'est
une histoire compliquée cette partie du
récit je les reconstituent émotions oui
oui elle elle explique aux patrons de
sipa qu'elle ne se sent pas capable de
faire ce reportage seul d'affronter
n'imagine pas que ce soit
conflictuelle mais d'affronter une
personnalité comme nicolas hulot il a 42
ans elle en a 19 et elle elle est tout à
fait heureuse que on lui propose d'aller
faire et ce reportage mais elle veut y
aller avec un journaliste qui a déjà de
l'expérience un photographe qui a de
l'expérience et le patron de sipa
accepte cela d'accord et lui dit
d'accord je comprends écoute tu iras
vous irez à 2 faire à ce reportage et
puis la veille du départ sipa lui dit tu
vas y aller seul finalement on compte
sur toi tu as du talent elle n'a rien
fait jusque là comme personne n'a vu son
travail photographique en a pas fait on
compte sur toi tu as du talent on a
confiance en toi plus à toute seule et
elle y va c'est une situation curieuse
quant à elles reviennent qu'est ce qui
s'est passé au fond il y a deux
personnes qui savent ce qui s'est passé
à 3 elle revient elle donne les
pellicules c'était comme ça à l'époque
assis pas et elle lui dit je
travaillerai plus avec vous je m'en vais
je disparais j'avais envie de faire du
photojournalisme et bien je ferai autre
chose et elle disparaît et on n'entend
plus parler d'elle onze ans plus tard un
an plus tard elle éprouve le besoin 11
juillet 2008 ça c'était angers en 1997
elle éprouve le besoin de franchir la
porte d'une gendarmerie
pour raconter à des gendarmes ce qui
s'est passé selon elle en corse dans
cette villa avec nicolas hulot ce sont
les gendarmes qui sur le procès-verbal
met le mot de viol sur la feuille elle
raconte seulement et e elle raconte et
on peut imaginer on peut imaginer que
les douloureuses bien sûr pour faire
cette démarche onze ans après et ce sont
les gendarmes qui dans cette on dit que
ce sont de vrais seins et ça me le
disent les femmes ne disent que les
fonctionnaires de police ou les
gendarmes ne sont pas formés pour
recueillir des manettes de cette nature
visiblement cela l'était mais en tout
cas ils ont eu la psychologie suffisante
pour l'écouter et le but que poursuivre
et cette femme était que nicolas hulot
et le dis comme ça dans le papier de
l'hebdo
comprennent le mal qu'il lui avait faits
c'est ça nicolas hulot est informé de
cette plante fin août 2008 de sa propre
initiative il franchit la porte d'un
gendarmerie je pense de saint malo ou
pour donner sa version des faits oui il
ya une relation sexuelle mais elle était
consentante et le procureur de morlaix
ensuite en octobre 2008 les faits sont
prescrits au bout de dix ans la jsr
n'inquiète pas le procureur de morlaix
très étonnamment écrit que de toute
évidence et les faits ne sont pas
établis c'est curieux parce que la
justice ne fonctionne pas puisque les
faits sont prescrits il n'y a pas d'
enquête il n'y a pas de confrontation
est il écrit un truc qui aujourd'hui
sert à l'avocate de nicolas hulot qui
fait le tour des rédactions pour dire
les faits ne sont pas établis enfin il
marque ça sur une feuille mais personne
n'a enquêté puisqu'il avait prescription
la justice ne peut pas dire les faits ne
sont pas établis et les faits sont
prescrits il doit choisir sa voie mais
faits étaient prescrits donc personne ne
sait ce qui est un tablier ce qui ne
l'est pas nous ne connaissons rien rien
donc a jamais eu de réelle enquête non
personne puisse avoir
des gens viendraient en angleterre donc
nicolas hulot est venu donner sa version
pu terminer chacun est reparti c'est la
photographe a donné sa version me
concerne nous a donné sa version et la
justice a dit c'est prescrit circulez ya
plus rien à voir et nous avons
connaissance de la plainte en février
2010 exactement donc encore dix ans
c'est une histoire de fou parce que ya
dix ans qui se passe entre les faits et
la plainte disant six passes en deux ans
entre eux les la pelote et les voilà
qu'on l'a fait elle est devenue publique
c'est mou se rappelle tous à moi j'étais
je m'appelle j'étais dans ma loge et on
m'a dit tu vas voir pour hulot il va y
avoir un truc groupe qui va sortir dans
l'associatif réduction à partir c'est
l'homme temps nous connaissons cela oui
le papier des d'où sort le 9 février
2010 8,1 m dos et un hebdomadaire et qui
a disparu aujourd'hui ne fait rien 2018
et qui nous apprend dans un papier il ya
une plainte contre nicolas hulot nicolas
hulot en 2018 est l'un des principaux
ministres la ligne aile maintenant on se
rappelle très bien c'est pas rien quand
bien sûr nicolas hulot intervient chez
jean jacques bourdin bfm et rmc rmc
veille il avait appris formidable coup
de communication nicolau nola l'extrait
tous les repas je termine je les ai
avant de rentrer dans le bureau de dans
le studio de jean jacques bourdin
nicolas hulot a préparé son intervention
avec un spécialiste de communication de
crise il n'y a pas été sans munitions
jean jacques bourdin n'a pas lu le
papier ça se sent à ces questions je
vais préciser ça après peut-être qu'on
peut l'écouter à les y regardant d'un
petit extrait oui on parle de faits qui
ont 21 ans et sur une plainte qui a été
déposée en 2008
cette plainte a été classée sans suite
parce que non seulement
ces affaires étaient prescrites mais ça
ne suffit pas mais parce que l' enquête
j'ai été auditionnée par les gendarmes à
ma demande issue elle est confrontée à
cette jeune formé pas été confronté j'ai
été auditionné et les enquêteurs à
l'époque très rapidement on considérait
que y avait absolument rien qui
permettait de poursuivre c'est donc
l'affairé a été classée sans suite elle
a été classée sans suite est vrai skate
les enquêteurs aimeraient estimé puisque
c'était prescrits c'est simple les
anglais peuvent vraiment enquête la
machine judiciaire est bloquée puisque
la prescription
jean jacques bourdin pose plusieurs
types de questions mais souffrir ça vous
fait mal vous allait démissionner et
évidemment nicolas hulot il souffre ça
lui fait mal c'est sans doute je vais
démissionner nord l'interviewer braqués
sur nicolas hulot mais est 7e cette
communication la abouti à un résultat
incroyable il entre dans le studio en
étant accusé de viol et il en ressort
comme victime que fait manuel mâcon tout
de suite derrière emmanuel macron fait
dire par son porte parole qu'il
accueillait cette information un de ses
ministres accusés de viol avec une
sérénité de marbre moi ce moment là je
me suis dit c'est pas possible personne
n'a relevé ça mais moi ce moment là j'ai
pris ça comme un coup de poing comment
voulez vous lutter
comment voulez vous encourager les
femmes à parler quand elles se disent
victimes de la violence des hommes si au
sommet de l'état une accusation de viol
moi je suis de marbre c'est incroyable
alors est-ce que ça fait 1 arlette
schiappa marlène schiappa trois jours
après si un texte dans vol du dimanche
j'ai beaucoup de respect des steam pour
marlène schiappa parce que c'est une
femme courageuse qui s'est beaucoup
engagée dans les violences faites aux
femmes
marlène schiappa le dimanche 11 février
2018 signe un papier dans le journal du
dimanche où elle écrit nicolas hulot est
un type bien
sous-entendu la femme qui porte plainte
contre lui n'est pas une femme bien ce
jour là hélas je regrette
marlène schiappa à déserter de son
combat et à partir de là la pression fou
l'accusation de viol mais bon il ya des
choses plus importantes jean-michel il
ya des liens ya encore d'aller voir
c'est incroyable ce que va nous raconter
jean michel qui a énormément enquêter
est ce que c'est une affaire qui se
savait dans certains milieux en moins
nombreux vous nous aurons non non parce
que quand la sphère bien public il ya
trois ans vous dites que l'écho
journalistes ont manqué de curiosité
amène à dire par là bas ils ont ce qu'on
m'a dit dans le lien moi je me suis dit
tout de suite que ce qu'il fallait
restituer mais je ne savais pas dans
quel cadre je le ferai si un jour je le
ferai d'ailleurs parce que j'ai
raccroché sa au livre mais bon voilà je
je je me suis tout de suite dit que
personne ne saurait jamais ce qui s'est
passé entre les deux pascal mitterrand
ne parle pas
là jamais raconté les fêtes qui s'est
vraiment passé pascal mitterrand ne
parle par est ok la victime un parent
alpes oui moi je me suis toujours dit
que ce qu'il fallait essayer de raconter
c'est comment un homme de 42 ans et
comment une femme de 10 neuf ans se
rencontrent j'ai travaillé là dessus
donc j'ai essayé de restituer
l'environnement de sipa en 97 et
je suis tombé assez vite d'ailleurs sur
un témoignage c'est compliqué qu'une
autre journaliste a récupéré une
biographe de nicolas hulot qui a
récupéré le témoignage du patron de sipa
goksin sipahioglu c'est ce qu'on entende
aux-in sipahioglu munichois il dit
nicolas hulot il a voulu cette
photographe elle n'avait pas de travail
personnel il avoue les ailes et je lui
ai dit reviendra compagne et ne viendra
seul
nicolas hulot a insisté pour ça donc je
le raconte dans le ciel le témoignage de
goksin sipahioglu on entend boxing
sipahioglu gelé il est là le patron de
sipa prix le patron de sipan et l'arrêté
mariage la voix de sipa et la thune jour
un journaliste bérengère manque qu'il a
récupéré qui a été avant biographe de
nicolas hulot qui a compris après coup
parce que quand elle a interrogé si pas
elle ne connaissait pas la plainte pour
viol ici pas tout seul raconte cette
histoire à bérenger remonte chez pas si
les gens suivent sur visiblement si pas
culpabiliser parce que quand cette jeune
fille revienne quel bon de les
pellicules lequel lui et qu'elle lui dit
vous me reverrez plus jamais il comprend
bien qu'il s'est passé quelque chose
donc culpabiliser il raconte ça la
biographe en 2009 elle passe à côté du
témoignage et quand en 2018 elle connaît
la plainte bravo pour ceux qui suivent
elle se dit [ __ ] si pam a donné les
clés et donc elle fait état du
témoignage de sipahioglu devant une
assemblée un peu particulière mais après
elle n'utilise plus ce témoignage manger
ce témoignage et quand on recompose le
puzzle on voit que cette jeune fille
n'est pas arrivé par hasard chez nicolas
hulot quels amis ressorti douloureuse
souffrante et blessés au point de
déposer plainte onze mois après et
dernier élément du puzzle
mazarine pingeot a écrit un livre
qu'elle publie en septembre 2009 la
fille de françois mitterrand donc la
tendance de pascal mitterrand elle
publie un récit où elle raconte comment
une photographe et s'est fait violer par
un prix nobel et elle assurait le jure
elle préférait va se faire découper en
rondelles que ça c'est un roman son
inspiration et romanesque ce n'est pas
la réalité
et vous avez toute l'histoire et moi ce
que je pense c'est que nicolas hulot
doit répondre à des questions des
questions sans doute plus exigeantes que
celles auxquelles il a eu à faire face
avec jean jacques bourdin parce que une
fois qui alors justement vous dites que
c'est bien le dire vrai c'est fini
répond plus vous dites que l'interview
de jean jacques bourdin et honteuse
aller au jeudi entre 8 g et qui n'ont
que
deux mais voilà vous dites je pense que
c'est une interview qui n'a rendu
service à personne ouais elle a mis la
faire sur des mauvais rails la
complaisance de l'interview est un
problème si on veut réfléchir aux
violences que les femmes subissent et à
la pointe extrême de ces violences sont
les féminicides tout est lié il ya des
femmes qui pensent que le corps des
femmes leur appartiennent il ya des
hommes qui pensent que leur désir est
plus fort que tout et que le
consentement soit là ou pas si ça n'est
pas un problème c'est un problème pour
toute la société cela fait si l'on veut
réfléchir à cela et évoluer sur ces
questions il faut que dans des histoires
comme ça nous posions les bonnes
questions la scène qu'on a vu à tour -
elle me fait souffrir mais nicolas hulot
souffre tout le monde de soufre
évidemment la personne qui a porté
plainte est aussi en souffrance la
manière dont la presse dans cette
histoire se détourner des souffrances ça
c'est une honte alors qu'est ce qu'on
fait depuis au moins un mois avant la
sortie aux mauvaises j'essaie d'aller
stick toutes les rédactions là dessus
des personnalités politiques des femmes
qui même ce combat mais les femmes qui
mènent ce combat ils sont isolés
solitaire c'est très difficile pour elle
et bien je peux pas dire que le retour
soit à la hauteur quelques journaux
s'ils sont intéressés voici l'opinion et
reporters et bravo à eux et lci m'a
aussitôt remis le parc de parler au
travail mais david pujadas m'a aussi
permis de parler de ça sur son plateau
quand j'ai présenté le livre mais il y
en a d'autres qui ne voulait pas en
parler mathieu n'importe quelle star
rentrer dans un commissariat pour
déposer plainte la plainte est en entier
dans voici closer ce que vous voulez 24
heures après comment expliquer que cette
plainte soit resté totalement un ami
pendant dix ans secrète c'est à dire que
forcément quelqu'un a fait en sorte que
ça reste secret non non la vue ou savez
un lavis moi j'observe la vie politique
depuis longtemps on pense que tout est
calculé tout est stratégie que c'est le
bordel
zar
l'animateur star ça ne sort pas dans la
presse je pense comme tout prêt à
chercher si quelqu'un a fait pression
c'est une fausse piste qui nous
détourneraient de l'essentiel avec
l'essentiel c'est que il faut regarder
aujourd'hui la question des violences
faites aux femmes sérieusement géraldy
j'entends votre combat et je le trouve
totalement les génocides en combat non
mais si vous allez quand même une parole
forte non c'est pas encore boxing
council la société pour tout le monde
mais sympathique on les médias justement
part de ces histoires de viols
d'harcèlement d'agression sexuelle on
parle d'une justice et on s'insurge
parce qu'on dit qu'on bafoue la justice
et que en ligne dans une justice
médiatique donc aujourd'hui le problème
en vrai de vrai c'est le problème de la
prescription la honte absolue c'est que
cette fille éventuellement peut-être
présumées victimes étaient violées en 97
et quand en 2008 elle pose une plainte
on lui dit ah non non non là c'est trop
tard mademoiselle oui on al hassaniya on
aurait pu enquêter c'est ça le problème
oui ça serait bien des médias les jeux
sony de la sas et la justice aurait
enquêté effectivement si la plainte
c'est ça mais la presse n'a pas de
problème pour parler de la sphère de
camille kouchner un abcès ya
prescription en effet vanessa spring
aura ya prescription des faits flavie
flament il ya prescription des faits
parfois la presse a du courage le
parisien récemment à publier toute une
page avec le témoignage de cinq
mannequin de l'agencé élite qui te
raconter les faits prescrits pour
dénoncer le patron de mélèze parallèle à
la presse allemande la victime veut pas
passer mais c'est pas un problème
des histoires victimes par la victime ne
veut pas parler pour la presse ça n'est
pas un problème c'est un obstacle si la
presse est un peu volontaire elle peut
surmonter l'obstacle vous dis juste que
comme vous le comparer à d'autres
histoires céder
la presse la presse a démontré en place
il faut bien savoir ouvrir des portes
enfants mais revenons n'est pas
jean-michel pourquoi avoir choisi
aujourd'hui de dans votre livre de
décidé d'évoquer cette affaire je
raconte les coulisses du quinquennat oui
ça me semble un moment important du
quinquennat d'accord ça me semble un
moment important pour deux raisons
d'abord parce que c'est la première fois
qu'un ministre que j'ai le viol comme ça
et je vous le dis comme je les pensais à
l'époque le président de la république à
une réaction sur laquelle il devrait
revenir je vois pour s'en excuser
on sait pas qui conseille emmanuel
macron
mais justement père marc saoudite de sa
non moi je trouve ces histoires
terribles évidemment on est pour le
combat des femmes moi même je milite
beaucoup pour ça c'est toujours très
emmerdant de ces histoires très
embarrassant est-ce vrai ou est faux
c'est ça qui est terrible ça peut
détruire un homme si c'est faux si c'est
vrai c'est scandaleux évidemment qu'il
soit libre moi je fais story de cette
histoire c'est toujours sur dix ans
c'est horrible vous condamner quelqu'un
déjà là il déjà condamné
pour de nombreux vols passent et
médiatiquement mais en sortant mais
attendez c'est pas la peine qu'on n'a
existé ou pas oui d'accord mais non mais
d'accord le témoignage de sipahioglu il
existe ou pas je peux pas mais telle
idée que moi je le condamne
ça veut dire on va papa à l'origine il
ya une plainte pour viol à bord ne parle
pas parce que employés c'est le combiné
je jouerai que
jamais plus je rencontre c'est important
ce que dit bernard c'est vrai qu'il ya
des gens qui vont dire photo jean-michel
willy rabat oui en pointant du doigt
sans rien faire jean-michel mais n'ont
rien à manger et bien le jury aucun jeu
complètement cela je ne dis pas que
quelqu'un est coupable jeudi qu'il y à
une femme en souffrance elle a
suffisamment de souffrance pour onze ans
après déposé plainte et si à cette femme
la seule chose qu'on est capable de lui
dire merde parce que c'est la
prescription merde parce que si on en
parle on accuse quelqu'un eh bien on
n'est pas de dire mais de vivre en
société rageant car je n'ai jamais j'ai
l'impression que via le combat mais que
vous voulez vous démontrer quelque chose
d'une protection
si vous avez le sentiment qu'on a
protégé délibérément nicolas hulot qui a
eu un souci on voit les
deux cultures je voudrais jamais d'un
acte en parler le dr manioc n'ont pas
obéi il est muni d'un problème de
culture est bon on en a parlé la culture
masculine reste dominante le parisien il
ya dix jours 15 jours lundi dernier pas
le lundi la signal à ses lecteurs que
c'est l'anniversaire de patrick par là
qui a 74 ans il ne s'est rien passé
entre les 64 et
les 73 ans qu'on en parle et là je m'en
vais mais est ce que vous vous rendez
compte de ce qu'il faut de d'absence de
sensibilité à ces problèmes là pour
signaler lundi dernier l'anniversaire de
batteries choir d'arvor est ce qu'on
peut réfléchir à tout ce qu'on a pas
réfléchi
les journalistes contre votre confrérie
contre la presse contre l'accusé c'est
pas une freak et le parler on peut pas
monter le la défaillance des
journalistes dans cette histoire il faut
trier ce que l'on désigné crois qu'ils
ont fait je voudrais vous avez raison
monsieur but
je pense que nicolas hulot doit accepter
parce que le témoignage de sipahioglu
apporte un éclairage différent sur cette
histoire il doit accepter de répondre à
des questions
les questions en ce moment un livre moi
j'ai pas envie de faire l'intérim au
foin mais la question c'est quoi les
questions
posées par contre vous jean-michel mais
là on fait le procureur
mais jamais on faisait un concurrent je
raconte une histoire oui il y avait des
éléments d'un puzzle qui était là il y
avait la plainte il y avait la réaction
des autorités de la presse et mettre la
théorie patrimoine y âge le débrayage de
sipahioglu et le livre de mazarine mythe
et la mort ces jeunes émancipés en 2013
jouer mais on l'entend dans le reportage
il a été interrogé en 2009 par bérengère
bonté et bien moi je me jeu je recompose
le puzzle et je pense que le puzzle
poser question jeudi il faut essayer de
répondre à ces questions est il bien aux
gens dont jean michel aphatie est ce que
c'est le rôle des médias aujourd'hui
d'accabler de juger un homme à la place
de la justice est-ce qu'on sort quand
ces informations vous n'avez pas
l'impression de participer un tribunal
médiatique aujourd'hui des journalistes
des médias les réseaux sociaux juge les
affaires à la place des tribunaux non
pas du tout je juge pas la faire je le
dis parce que vous pensez à nicolas
hulot quand vous sortez je ne marque pas
que quelqu'un est coupable avait
rencontré nicolas hulot
g2g eu de contact avec lui pendant qu
elle n'a pas souhaité répondre à mes
questions et vous avez essayé de lui
poser vos questions que vous posez dans
l'île
n'a pas voulu me rencontrer donc j'ai
pas posé de questions je lui et je lui
ai expliqué pourquoi je voulais le voir
il m'a dit très courtoisement d'ailleurs
j'ai toujours eu de très bons rapports
avec nicolas nous je les ai eu que des
rapports professionnels avec lui mais
toujours toi il m'a dit que de son point
de vue ils avaient tous dit quand il
était une fois donc qu'il ne souhaitait
pas y revenir c'est son droit mais va
dire quoi d'autre sociale mais c'est son
problème donc et on refait ma mère
demandait une question alors qu'on a
déjà eu la réponse est que la justice a
statué en fait mais la justice n'a pas
statué
il fait des essais pour changer
rentrée seront peut-être après d'accord
prescription donc on parle pas
comme camille kouchner d'avoir un
éditeur si on s'en tient à la
prescription un éditeur de dire non plus
pas comme vanessa spring morin va voir
un éditeur dans l'éditeur de livres mais
non madame c'est presqu'une que l'appel
à défiler des coupables
mais j'aimerais juste que ça sa mort
jean michel puisque vous pointez du
doigt ce que vous appelez les
défaillances de vos confrères que
qu'est-ce que qu'est ce que vous voulez
qu'il fasse c'est à dire qu'est ce que
vous qu'est ce que vous voulez quel est
votre théorie d'après nos confrères oui
mon passé ça sous silence merci que
c'était gênant pour le pouvoir non je
suis pas forcément
je dois d'abord j'ai pas trop de théorie
je suis pas venu pour ça moi si vous
voulez vous dites vous dites que vous
avez 18 j'ai trouvé que la société
n'avait pas bien fonctionné j'ai parlé
du président de la république j'ai parlé
de la personne qui était à l'époque
secrétaire d'état chargée de l'égalité
entre les femmes et les hommes est donc
chargé spécifiquement de ce combat j'ai
parlé de l'interview fondatrice de la
négation de la souffrance d'une femme je
pense qu'une société c'est me
semble-t-il ce que nous a enseigné le
mouvement mitu octobre 2017 cette
histoire date de février et 1018 on a
vite oublié les leçons comme le
mouvement mis tout ce produit on nous
dit il faut écouter les femmes quand
elles prennent la parole dans ces
circonstances là parce que la prise de
parole et des chercheurs les victimes se
sentent coupables il ya des femmes et
c'est
[Musique]
parce que senna prend pas la parole on
est rien
parce que si on dit quelque chose on est
un procureur non pas du tout si on met
dans ce cadre nous tous les éléments que
vous évoquez nous aboutissons à une
société du silence qui en paient les
conséquences c'est pourquoi cette
affaire des gens qui se la continuerons
à le faire c'est vrai bonne question de
savoir pourquoi cette affaire vous tient
tellement à cas on a l'impression qu'il
soit redonnée moi c'est d'ailleurs assez
touchant mais vous êtes animé cette
affaire mais tu aimes pas que si je
m'exprime avec les manches les retiens
je vous parlerai de castet m'accroche je
le ferai avec la même véhémence cette
affaire ne tiennent pas à coeur cette
affaire est une affaire importante pour
la société ce qui me fait un peu rageant
c'est que beaucoup de gens se détournent
de cette affaire alors qu'il faut la
regarder comment pourquoi mais je sais
pas le constat est là et après pourquoi
je sais pas que d'autres répondent vous
avez une opinion non mais je vois ce que
je pense que quand la victime ne prend
pas la parole c'est très compliqué je
suis beau fond de parler à sa place
c'est ça qui est toujours vous compariez
avec spring aura c'est la victime mais
dans les deux cas mais kouchner déjà
c'était
la victime ne tient pas dans le jdd que
j'ai évoquées pointe et cela elle disait
que les deux journalistes un jouet et
laurent valdiguié qui avait révélé la
plainte était des gens vraiment mauvais
puisque la victime ne voulait pas alors
c'est plus le mans c'est à dire qu'elle
a réagi son nom soit connu excusez moi
il nous faut qu'il ait connu il est
connu malgré moi le nom la plainte elle
est connue malgré moi une fois qu'elle
est connue on fait que oui mais c'est
bien laurent ça valait le nom par
exemple trouver le sabre est gênant
c'est affreux rationnellement on voulait
discrète cette fille alors je suis
d'accord avec vous et je suis d'accord
avec vous moi je ne cite que
exceptionnellement son nom je me cite
son manque de temps je parle du livre de
la nature on la connaît sinon c'est une
victime voilà mémoire et l'identité de
cette personne vous êtes citoyen c'est
fait jean michel a réagi sur votre livre
qui est victime
présumée victime présumée oui/non jeu il
ya des questions que je ne m'oblige à
des questions que le jeu n'ait pas envie
de répondre d'accord donc vous cachez
déjà réagi il ya des questions
auxquelles je ne réponds pas donc mes
cachets ne veux pas parler de la victime
à sa place je ne vais pas dire que je
parle avec dim je ne veux pas dire est
que je ne parle pas avec la victime moi
ce n'est pas la victime la
société et ses réactions et au fond au
fond au fond la société ne réagit un peu
comme sur le plateau mais qu'est-ce que
vous enverrez à dire
la messe est dite
quand même avec la table de cible ou la
paille ou blue qu'en fait son agression
était prémédité db c'est délibérément
choisi cette femme pour l'amener dans
pour l'amener dans sa maison de bel air
est encore solide pour elle je vous dis
quand on vous entend dire ça d'avoir sa
peau ça me glace mais je pense une
accusation extrêmement grave et c'est le
point de vue votre point de vue il est
directement pointée sur nicolas blot moi
je sais pas si c'est vrai ou si vous
dites vous dites ça parce qu'on n'a pas
lu le livre beige est mieux que ce que
vous me prêtez là c'est pas moi qui le
dis par mois c sipa ue c'est bien pour
ça que je relayais c'est bien pour ça
que je dis que c'est eux un témoignage
qui les pose des questions
si paillaugue lockheed et ça on pouvait
supposer ainsi que madame schiappa ou le
présent d'un public sont de bonne foi et
qui croit monsieur nicolas hulot alors
posé la bonne foi je ne sais pas moi je
suis président de la république
l'expression violent ça me laisse de
marbre j'ai vite
franchement je trouve une autre formule
franchement violé marbre je pense à
penser la raison a dit raymond chez moi
y'a un truc sur la prescription on est
tous d'accord c'est ça qui fout le
bordel après quand je vous entends dire
vous pas parlé à veux pas parler si elle
est rentrée dans une gendarmerie c'est
qu'il voulait parler sinon on ne serait
jamais rentré dans la gendarmerie pour
des débiles on sait que ça c'est m'en
voulez que je vous dise certaines
régions moi j'ai commencé là elle est
rentrée dans ce sens qu'elle a envie de
parler puisque après je vais oublier ce
que j'ai dit
c'est pas que c'est pas la même chose
moi je vois il dit que s'ils payent hulu
je sais pas conditionnelle il il à
l'enregistrement quand il dit qu'il veut
sept fils et moi ce que je trouve alors
j'accuse pas parce que c'est faux pas
envoyer un homme en prison c'est à
prescription faut pas envoyer n'importe
qui en prison si c'est pas vrai ce que
je trouve bizarre c'est qu'une gamine de
19 ans qui veut se lancer dans le grand
reporter photo qui scella jamais fait de
reportages aucun elle arrive là-bas en
corse chez nicolas hulot ça ne devrait
pas qui total elle va là bas elle
revient jette les appareils photos a dit
elle tout ça refoule viennent vous voir
ça car il ya quand même un truc bizarre
et elle part au total par ailleurs le
degré d'écoeurement il sait pas c'est
forcément quelque chose après moi je ne
dis pas qu'il a été défendu encore je
dis juste que c'est quand même pas
normal que la presse n'en a pas parlé
non plus je dis ça je dis que la
prescription il faut la changer et je
dis aussi il faut pas en mettre les gens
en prison comme ça pour rien sans
preuves parce qu'il se trouve nicolas
hulot il a absolument rien fait c'est là
que la gamine post ces appareils photo
etc à ce bar quand même un truc échangé
beaucoup parlé mais ce que je peux vous
répondre sur un poids vous pouvez une
question centrale que vous évoquez mais
je pense qu'il faut apporter une réponse
plus ouverte pourquoi une femme qui ne
veut pas que son nom apparaisse qui ne
veut pas que son histoire soit connu
malgré tout malgré tout cela
onze ans après les faits éprouve le
besoin saisir de franchir la porte une
jambe il
a pressé la prescription c'est ça qui
est dommage c'est qu'on son nom était
attendue face à cette dure dialoguer ou
genton comme cela là où la justice doit
être impartial totalement et juger
toutes les affaires moi je me pose la
question de la partialité des médias
pourquoi est ce qu'on parle de la sphère
nicolas hulot et pas d'une autre
pourquoi est-ce que des c'est ce que
cette affaire ressort en 2018 pile au
moment où ni par l'agglo ministre moi
j'ai l'impression qu'on a un peu envie
de se faire nicolas hulot entre
guillemets certains journée ils sont
vite pourquoi pas d'autres affaires il
ya plein d'affaires et des prescriptions
a plein d'autres affaires pas médiatisé
si vous en connaissez pour moi ca
ressort en 2018 quand il y six mois où
je vais vous dire très franchement moi
que c'est sûr qu'ils apprécient à
d'autres affaires enfin moi je suis à
d'autres affaires parce que vous trouvez
ça drôle des médias de se focaliser sur
certaines affaires et pas d'autres de
mettre en avant des affaires et pas
d'autres là où la justice vient de
tomber nous n'y a pas enfin c'est pas un
combat personnel moi c'est pas un combat
personnel il ya des déceptions c'est une
relation
eric zemmour oui qu'est ce qui dit dans
son livre le dernier la personne relève
tout le monde s'en fout philippe le
délit d'emprise c'est une invention des
cheminements il a dit ça
c'est à dire que l'idée qu'il puisse y
avoir un homme qui profite d'une
situation de pouvoir quel que soit le
pouvoir qui la fonde chez les inventions
de féminisme c'est ça aujourd'hui
l'idéologie dominante je pense que c'est
une idéologie qui causait beaucoup de
dégâts donc ça michel vous pensez que
nicolas hulot
je crois pas que ce soit une idéologie
dominante aujourd'hui la reprise
heureusement les choses ont beaucoup
progressé heureusement le film ben hur
il a redit dans la présidence de la
république et son bonheur dit d'accès
etc quels sont les journalistes qui met
eric zemmour face à ça
on va le recevoir bientôt voilà dire si
vous voulez non je n'ai pas à votre jean
michel merci en tout cas d'avoir été là
les amateurs les coulisses d'un
quinquennat chez flammarion
[Applaudissements]